[Music]
ryan is in portland oregon hey ryan
welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave thanks for having me
sure what's up
so i have some friends that moved to
texas they've been pretty much telling
me all about you and i've been trying to
follow your youtube channel for last six
months
and they've been telling me i need to
sell my cars and i don't know if that's
the wisest decision and here's where i'm
at i own both of my cars
i just got down to owning both of these
but i currently have 17 000 in credit
card debt i'm trying to get all down and
i'm about ready to have a sixty thousand
dollar student loan
stop stop stop you're about to have a 60
000 how do you just grow one of those
when you're trying to get out of debt
that's funny she's in school right now
and she's almost done with school and
that's the reason why i'm gonna oh the
loan's already there you just she's
about it's about to come to you
yes oh okay that makes a lot more sense
okay they're telling me i need to sell
these uh cars that i own which i don't
know if it's the smartest decision
because now i own them both and they're
telling me i should sell them and try to
find something cheaper yeah are you
married i'm just kind of curious i am so
she is your wife okay good yes all right
and how much are the cars worth each
um i'd say my truck's probably between
10 and 13 and my wife's suv is probably
between eight and ten
okay and what's your household income
um right now since she's working
part-time it's about 110. okay what will
she be making when she graduates and the
student loans come to you
um i'm guessing she's going to be around
the
a 200 75-100 household income give or
take and that's the coming this summer
right
yes in august okay and you got a 60 000
student loan and 17 on credit cards and
a couple of cars worth around 20 grand
yes
i agree with you not your friends i
think you ought to keep the cars
you think i should keep the cars yes
okay but i think you need to bust your
butt and pay this debt off in less than
one year
less than one year i was shooting for
two but why you're making 200 right now
you've been living on 110 you're getting
rid of your income all the way to 200.
why do you have to spend it all you're
not in congress
no you're right my wife's uh very
passionate about we need to find a
different place to move we went where we
are so
well so go rent something different
the price is just
you got to get out of debt
you need to get out of that
and you're broke you have no money
okay broke people who buy houses become
broker that's why they call them brokers
that make sense yeah please wait a year
go rent something else if you hate the
place you're in go rent something else
that you hate even more because renting
is temporary and get these get these
credit cards paid off and the student
loan paid off and keep your two cars
okay listen if you do part of this
advice it don't work
no i agree with you this is what i've
been following since i've been following
you for the last six months i've already
paid 10 000
of my debt off and i know if i want to
have talked to my friends in december
about this i would have been in more
debt and longer than less
so i admired before we came out that's
before we came upon your insistent wife
yes
[Laughter]
we need to follow this we need to do it
now and i'm like okay what do we do oh
oh she's insistent
oh yes okay but except for the part
about buying a house while you're still
broke right
no she just wants to move whether we buy
a house or oh good i'm with her i'm with
her over at
it's really inexpensive because i've
been here so well
you're living in a gross place and she's
right you're asking your bride to look
at a dump go rent something decent go go
rent something decent you make 200 grand
yeah i mean this place you were living
in there before you all got married
weren't you
yes i knew it it's a dadgum bachelor's
pad gross man
yeah i've been here for almost 13 years
oh it's really gross it's super gross
yeah she's exactly i can actually smell
it this woman this woman is smart yeah
yeah she's smart yeah you need to follow
her lead go get you a decent place to
rent for a year it doesn't have to be
the freaking taj mahal but it's just not
gross
and uh and then work your butt off and
get out of debt hey i like you guys you
all are fun thanks for calling in and
hold on i'm going to put you into ramsey
plus with financial peace university in
every dollar we're going to pay for it
for the first year and get you guys in
go through that class go through every
detail and i thought your wife was
insisting on buying a house that's why i
was picking on her and i misunderstood
so i was wrong so since i was wrong i'm
going to give you stuff free
so it's pretty cool it seems like that
often oh yeah and if you are you don't
admit it so this is a double whammy here
it's double double you know bonanza yeah
this is crazy folks somebody marked this
day down in history quickly yeah you
know i think it's fun dave is that the
friends who are ramsey folks we're wrong
said they were wrong but they at least
were aggressive you know they're like
sell your car yeah these people are
gazelle intense right now yeah they're
they're like so the rule on selling the
cars is
if they're less than half your annual
income and you can be debt free in under
two years not counting your house and
you like your cars you keep your cars
that's our rule
so the intense dave ramsey people were
not following the rule all right because
he's he you know he's got a hundred
thousand getting ready hundred ten
thousand getting ready to be almost 200
000 income he's only got 20 000 worth of
cars so they're less than half and he's
only got 60 plus 17 77 000 in debt and
he could be debt free in a year
especially with her new income kicking
in and even with a higher rent because
he gets out of the gross 13 year old
bachelor pad
yeah it's a freaking science project you
have your wife living in oh yeah
it is really fascinating to know the
difference i've got two teen boys and a
teen girl and the living conditions that
men will put up with starts early my
boys basically live in squalor i'm
telling you in their bathroom versus
there are some ocd males but most males
will just live under a bridge they just
don't care it's true i mean just get me
a tent and a grungy sleeping bag and i'm
good
yeah i mean it's just it's and guys you
really have to be
reasonable with your with your wife i
mean it it does make a big difference on
me being able to play long ball on this
be able to have a long-term mentality
and keep playing through
and uh
moral the story is guys don't let
gazelle intensity make it gross
you know there's nothing in your plan
that says gross is okay so this guy got
to keep his cars but he lost his
apartment that's the net of the phone
call that's true yeah not bad not bad he
came out pretty good in this and ramsey
plus and he gets it and he got ramsey
plus and he got to keep his wife and she
was insistent about the proper things
not the improper things i think our work
is done here misunderstanding i think i
think we can just set that one down